saluden directo América de France 24 y
marinas ardiña nos acompaña en el
estudio Marina bienvenida a este nuevo
directo América de este año 2023 y vamos
a hablar de covid 19 este nuevo año
porque el invierno estamos viendo un
rebrote en muchos países también nuevas
medidas de contención para Los viajeros
hospitales saturados y una nueva sub
variante de omicron estamos hablando de
la xvb-15 de qué se trata todo esto
Marina Buenos días Raúl como ya venías
ya anunciando en el noticiero
precisamente el coronavirus vamos a
seguir hablando y muchos de 2023 y
precisamente de la nueva sub variante de
omicron detectada en octubre los
organismos sanitarios dieron la voz de
alarma por esta nueva sub variante de
omicron que fue detectada en octubre
como decíamos y hablamos de la Sub
variante xbb 1.5 que representa un que
ya está presente en una treintena de
países por ejemplo Estados Unidos ya
representa más del 44% de los contagios
totales según la Organización Mundial de
la Salud es la Sub variante de omicron
más transmisible detectada hasta ahora y
se propaga más rápidamente Y esto es
debido a las mutaciones que contiene que
le permiten adherirse a las células y
replicarse con facilidad ayudando a
eludir las defensas inmunitarias Esto es
lo que dijo la OMS Hace unos días
la xvv 1.5 se ha detectado en 29 países
hasta ahora puede haber más como la
secuenciación está cada vez menos
disponible a nivel mundial nos resulta
difícil rastrear cada una de estas sub
variantes de omicron Así que forma parte
de omicron como se ha señalado es de su
variante más transmisible que se ha
detectado hasta ahora
los asesores de la organización están
evaluando el riesgo que supone la
variante pero los especialistas dicen
que el aumento de los casos no igualaría
al primer pico de contagios de omicron
Marina le pregunto qué tan peligrosa es
esta variante bebé 15 bueno los datos Y
todavía la Organización Mundial de la
Salud no cuenta con unos datos
específicos sobre su peligrosidad ni
tampoco sobre unos datos clínicos de
cómo está actuando pero sí alertan y
dicen que debemos seguir con las medidas
de seguridad como la vacunación que este
es una de las medidas que se han tomado
y que se está replicando en todo el
mundo y que está ayudando si bien no a
los contagios pero hacía que los casos
no sean tan graves no acaben en
hospitales y no acaben tampoco en
defunciones por eso la OMS sigue
pidiendo Pues que acudamos a los centros
a vacunarnos y que tomemos medidas
preventivas como el lavado de manos o el
uso de mascarillas que hoy mismo
recomendó también que serían necesarias
dentro de los aviones en trayectos
largos claro Marina y también puede ser
responsable nosotros y sentimos algún
tipo Pues de afección respiratoria usar
un tapabocas y el domingo el coronavirus
en China Dejó de ser una enfermedad de
categoría a Marina mientras el gigante
asiático también relaja las y su
política de cero covid muchos países
como lo estábamos también hablando en el
noticiero pues imponen estas medidas a
Los viajeros procedentes de china que
está ocurriendo en el gigante asiático
Marina bueno los en el en el Asia ha
pasado de categoría a que era la más
peligrosa desde el pasado 8 de abril de
enero Perdón también china ha dicho ha
dejado de ser una enfermedad de
categoría y esto quiere decir que el más
el máximo de nivel de peligro que
conllevaba esta categoría que requería
unas medidas más estrictivas pasa ahora
a ser una categoría B que contempla un
control más laxo y que marca el fin de
la política de cero covid con la
reapertura de las fronteras esto Pese a
que muchas provincias sobre todo en
regiones más Rurales el coronavirus está
teniendo una alta incidencia en ghenal
por ejemplo la tercera provincia más
poblada de China casi el 90% de las
personas se ha contagiado de coronavirus
o en Shanghai con unas tasas del 70%, la
ciudad consumida en un colapso además
hospitalario y se espera que se
repliquen otras regiones debido a estos
viajes que están haciendo ahora por las
navidades y debido al nuevo año lunar
Por otra parte china pide transparencia
Estados Unidos y a otras naciones sobre
todo también en Europa que han impuesto
medidas para contener la oleada de
contagios como test negativos en los
aeropuertos a Los viajeros procedentes
del gigante asiático que está
respondiendo también como dicen los
virólogos con mayores medidas también
china últimamente ha dicho que va a
imponer medidas por ejemplo a Japón a
Los viajeros que viajen a Japón Esto es
lo que dicen los virólogos sobre la
alarma desatada por la relajación de las
medidas en China
por lo que sabemos china se ha abierto y
ahora está experimentando oleadas de
este y otros linajes de omicron en esos
contagios derivados de omicron no hay
indicios de que los virus de los que se
tienen constancia en China sean
realmente diferentes de los que hemos
visto en el resto del mundo después de
todo cuando china se cerró y luego
reabrió gradualmente los virus que
recibieron provenían de nosotros del
resto del mundo así que ya hemos visto
estos
virushley
no hay razón para pensar que vayan a
salir virus más peligrosos de China y
luego salgan a cualquier parte del mundo
de hecho si acaso china va por detrás de
nosotros en este momento en cuanto su
evolución viral
Marina y cambiamos de tema nos vamos
hasta Estados Unidos porque la fda
estamos hablando de regulador de
medicamentos estadounidenses permitirá a
hacías vender pastillas abortivas Así es
Raúl desde hace una semana la agencia
pública publicó una nueva normativa que
permite algunas farmacias incluso a las
farmacias en línea vender las píldoras
abortivas de mifepristona por primera
vez en la historia y en un momento de
alta polarización y controversia
respecto al derecho al aborto luego de
la anulación del fallo histórico Row
versus White y mientras muchos países
muchos estados conservadores buscan
prohibir también el aborto con
medicamentos sin embargo está regulación
no garantiza este derecho a las mujeres
de más de una docena de Estados
conservadores que como decíamos debido a
la supresión de este fallo de la Corte
Suprema han emitido prohibiciones
también dirigidas a la mifepristona por
lo que tendrán que viajar a otros
estados para obtener estos medicamentos
o pedirlos en línea entre los cambios de
regulación también está que ya no será
necesario que el medicamento sea
recogido directamente por las mujeres
sino que servirá con que estas con una
receta de un prescriptor certificado que
es la
mifepristonal es una combinación que en
combinación con un segundo medicamento
el misoprostol induce un aborto hasta
las 10 semanas de embarazo la
mifepristona se toma primero para
dilatar el cuello del útero y bloquear
la hormona
necesaria para mantener el embarazo y el
misoprostol se toma entre las 24 y 48
horas después para que el útero se
contraiga y se expuse el tejido del
embarazo estas píldoras tienen un alto
historial de seguridad y eficacia sin
riesgo de sobredosis o adicción de hecho
en Estados Unidos la mitad de los
abortos Raúl se producen con píldoras
abortivas y no con cirugías bueno Marina
como siempre Muchísimas gracias por toda
la información de salud mañana con más
aquí en directo América nos vemos mañana